Monday was ibrahim's favorite day of the
week this was a Boy Who Loved school so
much that even the night before he died
he finished his homework
but it's in the classroom his mother
thinks he caught strep a she says she
pleaded with doctors to treat him when
his symptoms persisted even after a full
course of antibiotics I said please give
him something because his stomach is
hurting very bad give him something and
she said no he's fine he'll be better
give him water and calpol all the
children have a bug
on November 14th Ibrahim collapsed he
died minutes later in an ambulance on
route to hospital it was a Monday
Ibrahim is among a growing list of
children in the UK to have died with
strep a in recent weeks
this is Cove school in Lee in southeast
London this week they sent out a letter
to parents informing them that one of
their students had sadly died it says
that the risk of strep a to other
students is low and it gives parents
advice on what to do should their child
develop symptoms
Sky News understands that the child was
a year 8 student and is therefore not
included in the data released by ukhsa
which only includes deaths in the under
10 age group
a is a common winter infection usually
caught in schools and caused by bacteria
that affects the nose throat and lungs
it can spread through coughs sneezes and
skin to skin contacts symptoms can
include a fever rash or flush cheeks
well we do occasionally see um group a
strep infections in younger adults and
older adults or middle-aged people but
they tend to be less severe having said
that of course it's not unusual it's not
unheard of for uh people to to have
really quite severe group a infections
so it does happen
High news has reached reached the
organization 's GP services in
buckinghamshire for a comment UK Health
officials say death and serious
complications from strep a remains rare
as concerns grow that more cases May
emerge over the coming weeks ibrahim's
family say health officials must treat
other children faster Sadia Chaudhary
Sky News